les yeux dans les yeux est ce que c'est
vrai que vous avez levé sans ce petit
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous on joue à la tête
ou les faits que vous jouez avec nous
des questions médias pour certains et
pour d'autres on veut des pas le zougois
m logan et sa fiancée qui s'intitule
comme l'oceane l'atlantique à la maison
et libasse vous allez devoir lever 20 kg
pour gagner varrault et 10 kg vous avez
dj kg 10 kg trois fois en natation c'est
bien sûr la poitrine et je suis très
inquiet d'un haut responsable noir en
faire quoi répondre et resteront mais
comme là jusqu'à un certain point on est
sûr qu'il n'arrive pas à me laisser la
laisser là
enora on peut passer à 30 euros la barre
est à tout et à combien la 30 kg et non
à vous devez en faire trois
[Applaudissements]
sympa parce qu'ils doivent ou non
attention c'est thierry moreau apprécié
mamour une môme à 50 kg 1
et mes positions avec les fera pas le
moins 50 blessés côté des gros
[Applaudissements]
mais l'améliorer on était seuls evans à
rené cdc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ça
rien lever et on peut pas valider ce que
pour en faire une seule tasse à la bcc
dément c'est bien tout
de tels pics gonfler la du coup vous
avez les chéris 50e mais grâce à mathieu
de l'embout vous allez pouvoir
multiplier cette somme par dix ont nommé
les foules et peut-être gagner 500 euros
matthieu delormeau il ya de kehl ça
quelques jours vous nous disiez ça allez
vous mettre en place oui mais non à
l'elysée pas tout dit au delà de la
force avec j'ai passé 107 kg ni cette
semaine au développé couché les yeux
dans les yeux est ce que c'est vrai que
vous avez levé chanceux qui oui mais
c'était la semaine dernière donc j'ai
vieilli déjà le goût pour les livres
c'est vrai non non je suis non mais
vraiment je jure ce l'effet maintenant
chez après 40 minutes on est chauffée
machin est tous là comme ça à froid vous
êtes malin
wen blessés risquent de déserter les
missions l'audience terminée merci m'a
dit c'est 8 clé sous la porte et dont
vous risquez de déserter les missions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi aussi
[Applaudissements]
quoi
black out fait gagner à logan et océane
hip hop vous remercier 500 euros + 1 an
d'abonnement une sale histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]